Hong Kong is a rich modern 21st century
city considered one of the top financial
hubs of Asia but many residents have
deep anxiety over how to make ends meet
one in five people live in poverty the
minimum wage is 4 euros and 30 and in
one recent poll two-thirds of residents
said they were unhappy with their
quality of life that's not a surprise
considering it has one of the world's
longest working hours and some of its
highest rents as the pressures mount
cramped families have little hope that
things will get better as DWS Matias
Bolinger shows us in this report Hana is
the youngest of a family of six sharing
this tiny two room apartment in eastern
Hong Kong she lives with her mother
Sammy the father and his family in
roughly 40 square meters and although
this is quite common for families here
the grandparents have asked us not to
film them and not to take any close-ups
of objects in the flat the flat is so
small that we have to use every corner
to store our stuff it feels like our
whole life is on display it's
embarrassing
the young family she has a small bedroom
for three others sleep in the living
room and hallway
Sammy's husband has to work two jobs
while she takes care of their daughter
to escape the tiny space she spends most
of the afternoons with her daughter at
the playground downstairs fortunately we
don't have any serious conflict most of
my friends have regular fights with
their in-laws because of the lack of
space
Hey stop calling me know whether we are
young people in Hong Kong find it almost
impossible to rent let alone buy a flat
terrain for a 25 square metre studio can
easily cost 2,000 euros per month an
average salary in the territory this is
one of the factors fueling young
people's anger in the current crisis now
the government has come up with a grand
plan to solve the city's housing
property we are reclaiming a land of
about 130 hectare of land from the sea
and this small Bay is just the beginning
three artificial islands are supposed to
follow a total of one thousand seven
hundred hectares they would be the
biggest such islands in the world
we are expecting that these artificial
islands will provide housing units for
some sports 400 thousands to 700,000
people and 70% of these housing units
will be public housing is for the hannam
people
but the project is controversial in the
city where official plans are often met
with suspicion opposition lawmaker cork
kaki suggests that there would be enough
industrial wasteland on the fringes of
the city that would be quicker and
cheaper to develop this is something
very peculiar the only reason that we
can think of why we need this project is
this land how reclamation areas is
actually at the center of so-called a
quicker Bay Area's that project is a
government initiative to integrate the
city's economy further with the Chinese
mainland since last year the words
longest bridge connects Lantau Island in
the territories west to zhuhai and macao
on the other side of the Pearl River
Delta the islands could link to the city
center
these issues have little impact on
Sammy's life her child will be grown up
when the islands are completed she is
betting on public housing yeah they
always see the Mae's house that we've
already tried five or six times but what
can we do we can't afford an apartment
on the free market so we'll try again
since we're a young family we're hoping
to move up the waiting list until then
she will do her best to get along with
her parents in-law and spend as much
time as she can outdoors and we have
journalists larell sure in Hong Kong to
tell us more often with political unrest
it goes hand-in-hand with economic
unhappiness I think a lot of people
forget for example that the students who
protested on Tiananmen Square back in
1989 it was happening in the context of
inflation in China without discounting
the genuine demands of people for a
political change talk a little bit more
about the economic challenges in Hong
Kong can they really be fixed whether it
can be really fixed is a question for
the government and honestly there are a
lot of solutions and the government has
a huge surplus they could be using a lot
of that money on building public housing
there is a lot of land that's not used
so there's a lot of solutions that could
help solve this crisis for regular
people I there is a graffiti that I saw
a few expect that I think really sums up
the sentiment that protesters feel and
it was a you know I'm paying 7,000 Hong
Kong which is about 700 euros for an
apartment the size of a cell and you
really think I'm out here afraid of jail
so I think people right now in Hong Kong
feel like the they don't have there's no
space for them in the Hong Kong's future
right now the city is not taking care of
them they can't afford to buy a house
they don't see a future for themselves
in the city the way things are going so
they're desperate and they basically
feel like they have nothing to lose so
they're fighting for Hong Kong they are
fighting for their future they're
fighting for their identities so I think
what we'll see is that protesters
this is their last stand and like you
said this is certainly exacerbated by
the economic situation larell chore
thank you